reg I was watching James Harden last
night in the Rockets against the Utah
Jazz and okay you know the play I'm
talking about right - it almost fell off
the challenge number one that it was not
called yes but the reaction afterwards
obviously from Twitterverse if you the
official number one what are you looking
at I thought that that was a point of
emphasis this year is calling those so
called travels and you and I have had
this discussion before about his regular
step back we think it's the travel but a
mandate a memo went out last season his
MVP here - all 30 teams saying it was
not a travel okay grant it is out of
trouble but last night come on man I
mean even Michael Jackson up in heaven
is rolling over to his grave looking at
the way he moon walked on that step back
step back but it sounds like he traveled
twice and they didn't call one of them
well you and I are on the same page yeah
is a travel but they don't call it so
yes you did travel twice his original
step back travel and then the setback to
the setback travel you got that and you
got the Euro step did you nobly
give us the Euro step yes that was all
do nobly yeah a little bit of it too
sarunas marciulionis okay he had a
little bit of that Euro step as well but
who made it famous and a sheik and in
thing was they were both in both left
handers - sure unas and Ginobli there
and James Harden see the left handers
are getting away with stuff reg oh
here's another one for you I don't know
if you had a reaction to this
Lil Wayne said you know the debate is
not Jordan LeBron he says that Kobe is
better than all of those guys
again this is all personal preference
and you'll hear a lot of Kobayashi
people probably say that it it's your
preference it's what you like Kobe's a
bonafide super super superstar he's in
that secret door in the hall of fame in
my opinion along with Mike but you've
got to put the broader there I mean you
can ask who's better who's the better
score who's a better defender who's a
better all-around you can't quantify
who's the best in my opinion if I'm
going if I'm starting a team today I'm
not picking none of those three guys
I'll probably would go with Kareem
abdul-jabbar as my number one guy okay
so it's your preference on who you like
when you grew up the era it's it's hard
I love little Wayne but that's his
opinion it's hard to say he's right or
he's wrong because you're gonna have
fans and built-in fan bases for all
three of those guys yeah I just I'm
curious how you make the argument for
Kobe being better than Michael and
LeBron like where where would you start
reason why I the reason why I can't
Trump Kobe over Michael is because Kobe
has said and you looked at the mannerism
and his game is all based off of MJ so
MJ he set the tone he was the originator
the duplicator with Kobe so how can I
put the duplicator over the originator
that's not going to happen
yeah but Brady grew up a Joe Montana fan
so Montana was the originator Brady the
duplicator and then I'm gonna put in
title okay right yeah one more time my
pick
Kobe s5 LeBron has three but again now
we're getting into I mean look MJ that
was my nemesis so I've played against
all three of them even though LeBron was
a rookie the year I retired
so I've dealt with all three of them at
one point in time Kobe was alone in the
finals in 2000 I mean he was just coming
into his own he was 20 21 and it was a
different color because later in his
he was a bona fide killer later in his
career but he was that complement to
their beast in the middle in Shaquille
O'Neal so he was just a baby when we
faced him in the finals Michael was a
few years older than me and was that all
my baptism he baptized me in all those
games so I got to go with MJ I mean just
because I've had so many battles with MJ
when we were somewhat in our primes but
MJ would get that not for me but again
I'm starting a teen today I'm going with
the cap in the skyhook hey I just heard
from Turner Sports you're gonna be in
the studio on Thursday you're not doing
a game on Thursday you're gonna be with
okay Sir Charles and Kenny Ernie
well I'll actually subbing in for Shaq
and the reason being is his son is
having that heart procedure get well
Sharif we're praying for you
so I'm subbing in for the big fella who
was with his family and his son during
this time so they went to the bullpen
and Mariano Rivera I like best of all
time it's seven ear inside the NBA
Thursday night with Ernie Chuck Kenny on
TNT starting at 8:00 Eastern if you
could have Chuck or Shaq as your
teammate will you take Jack okay when I
was a little too quick there I mean you
could get a little lob there I love
Charles but Charles is not commanding a
triple team double team that simple team
but what would he be like now though if
he was just starting out with this you
know attention given to big men who can
shoot three-pointers now which are we
talking about we're talking about
Orlando Shaq or 2000 dominated my Pacers
Shaq well you pick one but but how is
Shaq is Shaq different or is he the
unicorn that he's still going to be
because I still think that one day
there's a team that
we'll be counteractive to these threes
and make you guard them down low and and
try to make you play defense and play
their game as opposed to the other way
around but if you had Shaq now is he
just only down low the only problem Shaq
is going to have in today's game is
probably at the defensive end because of
players like milk itch and beed cat
because they're going to space the floor
and bring him away from the rim from
that paint area one thing that was a
flaw in Shaq's game is and what we tried
to exploit was put him in in today's
game tons of pick-and-roll because he
wants to sag off his first instant gets
to protect the paint can do that in
today's games were and we're using
today's rules according to you you have
to bring him away from the pain so
defensively that would be the only
problem in today's game for Shaq
offensively where you can't touch anyone
he's going to still be as dominant
offensively I know you know we see all
the sinners stepping out and hitting
threes and 18 and 20 footers that was
never Shaq's game but if you can't hold
you can't dislodge if you can't push him
in the back there's no way you're
stopping him when he's 5 7 10 feet away
from the basket he was just too strong
and too gifted and great footwork as
well but if you could pick one Center to
play with all time ok yeah Kareem
abdul-jabbar you talk about a unicorn
pass defense and scoring that's it
I'm happy and if a brawl broke out he
was going Bruce Lee on your ok he was
going Bruce Lee remember when he was the
last line of defense versus Bruce Lee or
whatever movie that was Enter the Dragon
yeah I'm going with Kareem Abdul what if
I said 1990 on that that's I think he's
underrated I I would take a kiemce over
any Center I think Kareem is the most
dominating player of all time and would
still be the most dominating player if
he played today
but Elijah one who I don't know if he
was even 610 or 611 but his footwork was
just unbelievable and I I just I loved
watching Elijah want loved but that was
it that was a treat to be able to cover
those NBA champion teams the adore you
and ie we've also had this discussion
before along with the Danette all-time
greatest five and I've remember five
years ago I said it was easy it was
magic it was Michael magic Larry
Hakeem and the cap Kareem
well it's kind of changed a little bit
because I still have Hakeem I put in
that power for cuz I said he wasn't a
true seven footer so he's my power
forward Kareem is my sinner but that
small forward position has changed for
me and remember how hard I told you it
was because Larry Joe was the guy I
patterned my game after growing up I've
got to put I kind of put LeBron in there
and Indiana please don't turn on because
you know how much I love you so Larry
Joe okay Larry Joe if Bird was healthy
and played 15 years then it may not be a
discussion cuz I would probably keep
Larry there but the injuries yeah Larry
was a bat Larry was a bad boy a bad boy
Jimmy this dude used to give it to you
and talk crazy noise to you so did you
talk back to bird I bathed I made that
one mistake by my rookie okay in Indiana
thinking I you know time noise Larry
Bird in Indiana where he's the hometown
favorite yeah he gave it back to me at
the free-throw line we smiled about it
we had a past Blue Ribbon after the game
and never last time I never talked to
him until he was my coach 15 years later
did you bring it up to him when he
became your coat was it ever title no
guys never talk about this stuff when
you when you're done playing when when
he was a coach no but this was Larry's I
mean this was brilliant about him
he would take all the money when he was
the coach of the
al Harrington Jonathan bender all the
rookies Jeff foster they all thought you
know because they had like big bubble
eyes oh my god Larry Bird and they
thought they were could really shoot and
compete against Larry I mean Larry was
in late 40s and that's the last thing I
tell you to always leave a player is
their shooting ability so he used to
just like kill those dudes in shooting
games I'm like man this dude still has
it Larry still has although he has it
now
no he was the coach of the Pacers you
had it I saw where a Blake Griffin had a
quadruple double last night points
rebounds assists in turnovers doesn't
count
wait what do you mean that doesn't it's
a quadruple I mean it's a negative
quadruple it's a negative quadruple
we're talking about fathers there's only
four positive
quadruple doubles in history yeah that's
a negative quadruple double and I was
telling these guys this story about
Alvin Robertson who played for the Spurs
and how he had a quadruple double with
steals and and you know your great
friend Mark Jackson tells that story
where they were playing dice with Alvin
Robertson and knew he was cheating but
they were so afraid of him they didn't
call him I played with some pretty crazy
dudes over the time obviously Ron Artest
comes to mind but was Ron crazy reg like
he wasn't mean it didn't seem like I
know no great great teammate but he did
flip a switch when he played sometimes
he could get locked in in the wrong way
and you have to look in his eyes and
bring him out of it but wrong was a
great teammate but Alvin was he he was
different
how about this he was just different he
was a different breed he C we heard hear
all the dudes in today's date he was
there every one of the days but he was
only like six three like what was it
about this guy that scared people he was
sick for his about 6-3 6-4 and he was
ripped and
he didn't know what look here's John
Wong who was my mentor at Indiana said
there's one guy my Ricky here 1987-88
you do not don't even look at him wrong
dude don't even say a word to hear I'm
like why reg you value your life and
career do not say anything and then as
time went on and I saw him in other
games I like oh yeah
okay think thank you John for saving my
career finish this sentence the more I
watch the Lakers this year I I'm
starting to like them I think I enrolled
are starting to be defined I think Lonzo
is playing much better to me Kyle Kuzma
has solidified the number two spot to
LeBron
it was Dwyane Wade it was Kyrie Irving I
think Kuzma has filled that that number
two slot but do you think Brandon Ingram
is there for the long haul because it
mean I don't either the more I watch the
more I go man it feels like he might be
expendable and you can and if the Lakers
and magic and polenka are smart you
could probably get something for them
right now
on 610 611 guy who can play you know two
or three positions I just don't think
it's a great fit with LeBron it has
nothing to do with his game it's all
about fit and right now Heart Ball Kuzma
those guys fit better with LeBron here
was another thing I found interesting
you know I love me some Sacramento Kings
but oh okay but the coach comes out and
basically says oops I think we made a
mistake in not drafting Luka Don chicken
and and Bagley's been okay he's good but
and then now he's been heaping praise on
Bagley it feels like any opportunity he
can get did Sacramento make a mistake in
not drafting Luka done check few teams
I'm sure what did Duncan's go
third or fourth with that trade with
Atlanta I mean Atlanta could be making
the same claim no Trey Young has I think
very young hasn't shot the ball well but
he's had moments he's had some big games
I think oh I think didn't they make the
trade with Atlanta Dallas did and did
Don chick go fit something like that
well how about this do you think Houston
or Portland thinks the same thing on the
Michael Jordan yeah
thing back in nineteen what 83 84 yeah
but it's weird to have a coach who's
saying you know Don chick has played
what 20 games and all of a sudden he's
he's sort of saying you know we thought
there was a ceiling there that he was
only gonna be so good and then know what
Theodore it's all about opportunity to
Don kids has been giving the keys to the
kingdom
obviously with dirt in the ankle surgery
though he's just come back to the last
two or three games so you know Luca has
started and Rick Carlisle has featured
him and he has you know produced results
it's been a little bit different for
Bagley and Sacramento and it's all about
the situation you're drafted into and
your relationship with your coach with
Manning management and the rest of that
team so some young players just take
longer to develop and we're seeing that
with Bagley but this guy has a world of
talent though alright so it was DeAndre
8 and then Bagley then Luca Don chick I
believe and that was the trade with the
Hawks
jaren Jackson jr. who I said I thought I
thought I was gonna be the best player
out of the this draft yeah he's had some
moments some pretty good games it's just
being in Memphis is not going to help
him I think stand out you know if he was
playing in New York or some of these
other bigger markets but you know I said
a couple moments there I think him
learning from Marcus all and now with
Noah being there that's going to help
his growth in his development well he's
only like 18 still some crazy like 19
and the same with Bagley patient
Sacramento patients oh gee
just let it develop your team is playing
well you have a deep bench let's say you
know don't crush it don't crushes his
confidence now not to say that he it's
crush but you kind of got a spoon fees
these younger guys in today's generation
I was reading in the New York paper The
Daily News where the Knicks were telling
the younger players not to go out with
Joakim Noah because his nightlight like
he was killing it he wasn't killing it
on the floor but he was killing it and
then in nightlife and so they he might
have been doing triple doubles off the
court but they actually said don't go
out with Joakim Noah and Noah even said
it's a great thing that he got out of
New York because that might not be alive
some people are you know can can handle
big cities and big moments and the big
city nightlife obviously Joakim Noah
cannot did you have a teammate like that
like first team all nightlife no I mean
you don't have to mention the name but
did did you I mean it's better if you do
but did did you have a teammate who was
just every team has one out of all 30
they have players that are now that damn
Travis best was killing it at night
[Music]
Detlef Schrempf I knew it
[Applause]
[Music]
- turning Rodell just kidding jaylen reg
gets to sit at the big-boy table
Thursday night get to be there with her
shucks Kenny you should could you beat
Kenny in a sprint to that big screen
Theodore you could be kidding really
it's look the way those knees are
touching one another one way from a
double ACL last is right he is one win
away from a double ACL all right we'll
have fun
play nice I will you - thank you brother
four more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show at
[Music]